Goodwill of Southern Nevada is
partnering with health care companies to
provide jobs 8 news now reporter Mary
Jane beliesa takes us to their
headquarters where students are training
in the medical field
Audrina chai was feeling stuck in life
when she knew she wanted to change I
went in to help people but financially
it wasn't really affordable until I went
on to Google found Goodwill chai is
talking about Goodwill of Southern
Nevada's one-of-a-kind training to hire
programs students can learn to become a
medical assistant or a certified nursing
assistant in under a few months to know
that I'm being paid to go to school it's
helped me tremendously it's those
rewarding moments that made LaToy
Clemens want to become an instructor we
still stay with the students we still
talk to them all the time and we
constantly get text messages phone calls
emails to tell us how much they
appreciate us instructor Michelle
Singleton knows programs like these will
help with the high turnover rate in the
medical field and it's demanding you
know it's a demanding field you got to
be really caring and empathetic Andre
Robinson graduated from the certified
nursing assistant program last year and
was eager to get in the field the CNA
training session only takes a week I
took that opportunity to show growth and
definitely actually give my son a better
view on what you can do in life and not
just be stuck in the same area it's
career and financial stability Goodwill
hopes to provide for their students and
their future while giving back to the
community thanks to Goodwill I do make
double what I was making before and
because of that I actually have tuition
reimbursement with the hospital I wish
they had this 20 years ago you know I
could have been maybe so much further
along in my career you know maybe helped
a lot of other people